>>Seth Ladd: Okay. I think we're going to
get started here.
First, thanks everyone for your time. Definitely
after lunch we'll try to keep you energized
and motivated here.
So this is Super Browser 2 Turbo HD Remix:
An Introduction to HTML5 Game Development.
My name is Seth Ladd. I'm a developer advocate
with Google. That means we work with partners
of all different sizes, helping them get up
and running on Chrome, HTML5, and the Open
Web Platform.
I focus on games, and so this is a topic very
near and dear to my heart.
Certainly reach out to me online, either Twitter,
my blog, or definitely at the show after this
session or around. I'll be in the Chrome sandbox
area. Love to hear your stories about what
you're doing with HTML5 and games, so definitely
reach out. I'd love to chat with you.
Also, after this session, we will be running
a Google Moderator. This link is up here.
This also works for everyone at home as well.
So we'll run through the top moderated questions
as well as like live questions from the audience.
I want to get started, though, with a quick
little story. I want to take you back to 1993.
My buddies and are down in the basement playing
Dungeons & Dragons, drinking a lot of Mountain
Dew. You know, good times. Typical Friday
night.
And so he asks, "Hey, do you have a modem?"
I said, "Yeah, I do. We totally have a modem."
So we all run upstairs. He says, "I'm going
to download this awesome game for you."
So we said, "Okay."
So we run upstairs and we yell down, "Don't
pick up the phone," which is how you got on
the Internet back in those days.
And so after a couple hours, we ran back upstairs
and we -- he unzipped and he says, "Get ready.
Check this out."
And what game is it? But it's Doom. Doom?
Yes. Doom defined the first-person shooter
genre. This game totally blew us away. We
stayed up all night playing this game. It
was our first all nighter for games, and so
our Dungeons & Dragons meet-ups turned into
LAN parties. It was really a lot of fun.
I went home, bought all the different levels,
upgraded my machine, bought everything it
ever made. I mean this was really, really
-- this was an impactful moment for gaming.
Especially for me and my friends.
So what can that little story kind of story
us and set us up for the talk?
Well, certainly you could see there with even
with BBSs back in those days, digital distribution
is key.
EA's CEO just recently said, "Virtually everything
we're doing now is against the digital opportunity.
It's where we see our growth."
So even BBSs back then, and the web today,
just click and play, digital distribution
is awesome.
As you heard, I bought everything ID ever
made, all the Quake episodes, all the Doom
episodes, shareware, got really into it.
Gamers spend money. For instance, just a recent
report here, "U.S. virtual goods market will
reach 2.1 billion overall in 2011." And this
is just virtual goods.
Games monetize in a variety of different ways.
In-app subscriptions, micro-trends, virtual
goods. So gamers spend money.
As I'm sure many of you also have, you've
upgraded your video cards, your CPUs, et cetera.
Gamers upgrade. You upgrade your console systems,
and I believe that this trend continues onto
the web today where gamers will upgrade their
browsers. And so I want to encourage all of
us to think of it that way as we build our
great HTML5 games. Users will come to you
if your game is awesome.
But probably the most important part is games
create emotional responses, really emotional
memories, and I still have that feeling of
staying up all night with all my buddies playing
all the game all the way through, totally
amazed, you know, bloodshot in the morning.
This was a really good feeling. I'm sure many
of you also remember that time you beat that
level after 150 different tries, or you finally
beat that arcade game with your friend. I
mean, these are really powerful emotional
responses and that's something you want to
capitalize on when you add games into your
toolkit for your products and services.
So what are we up to today? Well, we're going
to learn how to build a simple HTML5 game,
so we're going to teach you the tools to add
game development into your toolkit so that
you can create happy and engaged users.
But really, we're going to blow up some aliens.
So remember this is a 101 talk so this is
targeted towards the JavaScript developer,
the web developer. Maybe you know some jQuery,
maybe you've built some interactive websites,
you've probably maybe built an app or two,
but you've never done any game development.
This is the talk from you. We're going to
zero from hero, from start to finish, all
the way through in about 45, 50 minutes.
So let's get started. Let's build a game.
The game we're going to build from start to
finish is this little gem I whipped up here
called Bad Aliens. Aliens are coming in, attacking
our ship -- or our planet -- and if we had
audio -- yeah? No? Okay. Well, really cool
audio. (Sounds) That's more like it. Excellent.
Then we're going to do this from beginning
to finish.
So it's a fairly straightforward game, kind
of simple here, but there's a lot of moving
parts, so let's break it down here. Throughout
today's talk, we're going to build the space
using canvas. We're going to figure out how
to draw images like the aliens and the explosions.
We're going to add movement and animations.
We're going to set up our correct timing in
the game. We're going to have image rotation.
We're going to reduce work by using off-scheme
canvases, turret and mouse tracking with input
control, shooting, lasers, exploding with
animation, including detection, sounds, of
course, score keeping. We're going to figure
out how to monitor the performance. And we're
going to make the whole game work offline
and we're going to start that right now.
Our first object here is to bootstrap the
game. We're going to do that by employing
HTML5 canvas.
Canvas is a 2D drawing surface. You can think
of it like a bitmap surface. It's an immediate
mode drawing surface. That means everything
that you draw into the canvas immediately
is applied.
You can think of it like you have a paintbrush
and you paint on a piece of paper. That paint
is there. You can't get that off.
Contrast this a little bit with something
like SVG, where SVG is more DOM based and
you can, you know, manipulate the nodes in
SVG and it will kind of reapply itself. But
canvas is immediate mode.
Canvas has primitive APIs -- or APIs for primitives
like lines, arcs, gradients, and the one we're
going to use a lot in this game where you
can draw images straight onto canvas. Canvas
also supports transformation and scaling where
you can manipulate the coordinate space and
the coordinate system directly on the canvas
as well.
It's important to point out that canvas is
being hardware accelerated in modern browsers
and this will continue, and so this is very
good for performance for HTML5 games.
And you're probably wondering well, what about
WebGL? WebGL is a 3D context so that's native
3D into your browser. It's essentially OpenGL
ES 2.0, all driven by JavaScript.
WebGL is very important, especially for gaming,
and it's a little complex for the normal JavaScript
developer and so you'll see APIs beginning
to appear that can raise the abstraction level,
make it a little bit more approachable. You'll
see WebGL being very important for 2D as well
as 3D games, but for today, we're going to
focus on canvas.
So the canvas code, very simple. We have a
simple HTML5 document here and we just declare
that canvas is an element in our document
and set the width and height and that's all
we need to have a hundred percent or more
void of space. Doesn't look like much but
we got to start somewhere.
So next, now that we have space, we want to
figure out how do we render images on here.
Well, we're going to draw images directly
onto the canvas. We also want to make sure
that we load all these assets and images before
we start the game. As you know, images come
in essentially asynchronously or in parallel
so we want to queue them all up and download
them, wait for them, and then start.
As you notice, the planet is in the center
of the screen. We need to figure out how to
draw that planet square in the center there,
so we're going to introduce an asset manager.
An asset manager queues up the downloads,
he waits for them all to finish or error out,
and then signals that our game will start.
To draw images, we're going to use canvas'
draw image call, which takes one of those
images we download in an XY coordinate and
will draw it straight onto the canvas.
It's important to understand that this X and
Y from canvas' perspective is the upper left
of that image, and as you saw here, everything
needs to be centered around that point, and
we'll show you how to do the offsets.
And then because the planet is in the center
of the screen, to make our lives a lot easier,
we're going to use canvas' translate to move
that coordinate system.
So looking at the asset management code, this
is really straightforward stuff, but we're
going to be able to queue up the downloads
and we're going to be able to ask the asset
manager, "Is it done." I mean, it just asks
did everything either error out or succeed.
When we're ready to go ahead and kick off
all the downloads, it just loops through all
of our entities, sets up the appropriate success
and failure callbacks, and then here in the
highlighted code, we increment our counters
and then we can check after every callback,
are we actually done now, and if so, let's
fire off the game.
Now, as I mentioned, the -- we want to move
that planet into the center.
Now, canvas, by default, has zero zero in
the upper left. This is its -- this is his
canvas default orientation. But we want it
right in the center, because as you can see
everything is kind of coming in towards the
center, so to make our lives more easier and
to think about the game playing more like
a cartesian plain, where zero zero is in the
center, we need to move that.
Canvas translation to the rescue. You can
see a sample image here I got from the great
MDC website. We're going to use an offset
that actually moves that zero zero point down
for us.
So putting it all together in asset manager,
we're going to ask it to queue up the download,
and then when we're ready, say "Download all
and give it a callback."
When download all succeeds, we're going go
get that asset from asset manager, we're going
to translate our coordinate system here, you
can see, where you just essentially take canvas'
width and height divided by 2 and that moves
us right into the center. That's zero zero
now. And then we're going to draw the image.
Now, we want the planet at zero zero, but
remember canvas draws images from the upper
left, so that's the further offset here where
you take these sprites' width and height divided
by 2, and then as we see here, planet is smack-dab
in the middle.
So now we have a coordinate system, we're
drawing images to the screen, and we have
asset management.
Our next objective here is flying aliens.
This implies a couple things. Now that we're
going to add in a lot of different assets
into the game -- or sorry, entities -- we
need a game engine to manage all these things.
So we're going to add in a formal game engine
and we're going to formalize the concept of
an entity. This also implies that aliens are
moving around the screen and we need to calculate
things like velocity and animate them so it
appears like they're moving. So we need some
sort of loop. And a game engine or even simple
game code like this, when you boil it all
down, you have a simple loop of update and
draw. Update draw, update draw, as fast as
we can. That is, up to 60 frames a second.
Update loops through all the entities in your
system and updates their state, and draw loops
through all the entities in the system and
draws them onto your screen.
So as JavaScript developers, you're all probably
saying, "Oh, yeah. No problem. We have set
time-out, set interval."
In fact, this is not what you want to do.
If you use these methods, you are not conveying
your intent clearly to the browser and the
browser does not know how to help you.
For instance, your element moves off screen,
scrolls off, or becomes hidden behind a tab,
the browser has no idea that, oh, what you're
trying to do is efficiently and effectively
animate, and the browser doesn't know how
to integrate your code directly into the render
loop.
The browser manufacturers understood this
problem and introduced a new method called
request animation frame. This integrates you
directly into the browser's render loop and
the browser can now help you optimize. For
instance, if that tab, playing your game,
goes behind the curtains, if you will, the
browser can now pause the game, which is good
because the loop stops, you save battery and
you save CPU. This is all good.
So looking at the code here, our simple game
engine simply manages a collection of entities
and we have a master draw and we have a master
update loop and they just loop through the
entities and call the same method.
Inside the game loop, this is the function
that's actually called up to 60 times a second.
We have the update and the draw call in that
order and we also create a couple times -- time
deltas here so we understand how to calculate
things like velocity.
Then to start all this loop, we have a game
engine that's start. We have a nice little
inner function here that actually calls loop
and then calls again request animation frame.
So this here highlights that every time you
want to ask the browser to draw for you or
to be signaled when to draw, you have to ask
it again and again and again. So that's why
at the end of the loop here we reask to be
integrated in with request animation frame.
A quick note, really another benefit of request
animation frame, is that browser -- I'm sorry,
laptop displays, your monitors at home, they're
all running at 60 hertz, 60 frames a second.
Trying to do any work above and beyond that
is actually just waste of CPU, especially
for your draw cycles. And so request animation
frame knows this and will try to sync up with
that 60 hertz, so you don't even have to calculate
the timeouts.
So request animation frame is new and we have
browser prefixes in front as we work out the
kinks, so this nice little shim here will
help you future-proof your code by handling
the browser prefixes and then falling back
to set time-out if those -- if request animation
frame is not supported. I highly recommend
this blog post here, the title here, to learn
more about the benefits of request animation
frame and to get this shim.
So looking at our first entity in the system,
this is an alien. We have our update and draw
methods in here. You can see we update the
state inside update, where essentially we
move that X and Y coordinate, and then in
draw we just want to draw that sprite. And
remember we want to draw everything centered
around the point -- that is the X and Y where
we think the element is -- and so we just
introduce a simple method here, draw sprite
centered where we do the offsets.
So looking at that now, here we go. We have
aliens flying across the screen. We've got
entity managers. This is great but we have
a hundred percent more uh-oh. So I don't know
if anybody caught the bug that was introduced
in the previous code, but to illustrate it,
keep your eyes on the moving aliens.
So let's say I'm playing Bad Aliens and I
think, you know what? I want to play another
-- see what other cool games are out there,
so of course I go to the Chrome Web Store
and I'm browsing around the games and I'm
like, you know what, Bad Aliens is the coolest
game ever made and so I'm just going to go
with that. Whoa! Where did the aliens go?
So let's just catch that again. And because
-- remember, because request animation frame
has kicked in here, when I open up a new tab
like this, the game is paused, and we're browsing
around, (making sound), boom! They all kind
of jump around. I call this the wormhole effect.
So our objective now is to fix the timing.
So what's going on? If you remember back in
the loop itself, I was looking at the system
clock and calculating the delta before -- last
time my loop ran and then now and getting
this nice little time delta in here. But in
fact, because the game can get paused, as
we saw here with request animation frame,
and we jump back into the game, that delta
could be very, very large. And if you're basing
that off of anything like your velocity calculations,
you can have these tremendous wormhole effects.
That's not good.
So we're going to introduce our own timer,
our own in-game clock. We're going to ignore
the system clock and we're going to clamp
these deltas here to a well-known consistent
state.
So we're going to introduce a simple timer
here. The timer in its tick method, you can
see the highlighted code here is the kind
of key code where we do math.min between the
wall delta where a system time diff between
the loop is or our max step. So this is really
good because now we can pause the game. Everything
moves in lock step and this actually sets
us up for great multiplayer action, as well,
as we have a game clock now independent of
system clock, so you can tell events will
happen at a particular time in the game, independent
of people's FPS rates or machine speeds or
whatnot.
So inside the loop, we remove all the crufty
time code and we put in a simple clock tick.
This gets -- just gets set from timer.tick
and then back over in alien.update, we can
use in clock tick in replace of the older
system clock delta to calculate speed and
velocity.
So we have now a hundred percent less wormholes.
And they're slower here only because I didn't
sync up the timing.
So let's go back to -- we're going to pause
the game. Let's pause the game.
And everything picks up exactly where it was.
So now we have a consistent in-game time.
Our next objective, though, here to fix is
we're going to orient alien ships. We're not
quite as menacing as we possibly could. We
want them facing down Earth, so right now
they're all just pointing down and we want
them to all be pointing towards that zero
zero point.
So canvas to the rescue again with this nice
rotate call. Rotate takes radians and will
rotate clockwise. The important point here,
though, is rotate actually rotates the entire
canvas coordinate system, so we don't use
rotate to rotate the image and then draw,
necessarily. We actually move the entire coordinate
system for canvas around from that origin
point, draw the image.
So here's a good -- good image also from the
MDC site as well.
So there are couple steps here to make this
happen correctly. Our first step up here in
the red, we're going to translate our context
to the X and Y coordinate of our sprites.
We're going to move everything relative to
where we want to draw.
So you can see here when we draw, we're at
the upper left-hand of the image but at least
we're drawing pretty close to where we want.
In Step 2, we add in the rotation, so you
can see here now the image is rotated but
he's still offset.
So then in Step 3, we have the translate,
we have the rotate, but then we have to draw
that image offset based on his width and height
minus 2 again and now we're drawing the image
rotated and exactly on top of the point where
we want to draw.
We can add that code now back over to alien.draw
and you can see here we wrap all this fancy
manipulation here with save and restore.
So canvas again to the rescue. It allows us
to push and pop the state inside canvas, so
that we can manipulate accordingly. We can
translate and rotate all we want. And then
if we restore, we can pop off. That is undo
any of the changes we made, so that further
calls to the context are uneffected by any
of these changes.
So here we have a hundred percent more correct
image rotation. Great. Okay.
Moving on, we are going to optimize the canvas
code and save battery. So it turns out that
one of the roots of all evil of computer programming
is early optimization. Excuse me. But we know
that drawing to the canvas is actually the
toughest part of our game here, so we want
to optimize this code. So we're going to introduce
a cool concept called off-screen canvas. Off-screen
canvas allows us to create a canvas not visible
on the browser, but still attached. We can
draw things onto this off-screen canvas and
then use the canvas. Here in this code we
have rotated cache where we create off-screen
canvas. We do the same rotation and translation
we saw earlier, and then you return the canvas
and not the image. Here in alien, we call
rotate and cache. We get the image from the
asset manager. We do the rotation cache and
return it to the sprite -- return it as a
sprite. Now this sprite, which itself is a
canvas, can be treated like an image and drawn
over and all over. This is great. Because,
if you think about it, we would like the aliens
to loop around the screen. each one 60 times
a second was being translated and rotated
and drawn. Certainly, we can do better than
that. Rotation and cache only once. Turns
out it's a very big improvement. Here I just
looked with the developer tools. And 10 seconds
of game play. And we have on the right no
caching. That is, we do the rotation and transformation
every time for every alien. And, on the left
here, we introduce that off-screen canvas
caching. Only four milliseconds in all that
10 seconds was being spent. Huge performance
gains. It should be noted that once more canvases
become hardware accelerated, this difference
will minimize a little bit. But still it's
a good technique to do any work you would
do over and over again once and cache it.
So then we have 100% more effective image
rotation. Game still plays correctly, and
we're using a lot less CPU speed.
Okay. Now we had to add in our planetary defense
forces, which implies the matter of turrets.
And to add turrets to move around, we add
input handling. So we're going to listen for
clicks and mouse moves here. But, as we'll
see in a moment, those clicks as we get raw
event callbacks, isn't relevant to our game
space. We need to do offsets.
As web developers, you're probably familiar
with doing on mouse move or on click and then
handling whatever it is you need to do inside
the callback. But it turns out in games you
don't really want to do that. You want to
let the update loop manage all the state for
you. You don't want to manipulate the state
of your entities in the actual callback for
things like click and mouse move. So we're
going to store the click or store the fact
we have a mouse position and actually process
it later in the update loop.
So now we can ask the game engine to start
input. We have both input handlers, both click
and mouse move. And we call get x and y, which
is the method we wrote to translate the x
and y we get from the callbacks back into
game coordinate space. So, to look at what
this means, here is the raw client.x and client.y
code. If I were to click right in the center,
x is 522 and y is 399. That's not exactly
00 or close to it. So we need to figure out
how to offset that.
First thing we need to do is call get bounding
client rect. And do that offset first. And
we're at 516, 391. Little bit closer. That
offset is the white border between the documents
page -- document window and the canvas itself.
And then the final offset here, we're going
to take that and offset again from the canvas
width and height divided by 2. And it turns
out I clicked pretty close at 4 and 7. So
do you need to do this? No. But it's really
helpful to get that x and y -- those points
relative to your end game coordinate system
just makes everything a lot easier.
So here, turning that into code, same code
we just saw. We're going to turn the offset
x and y.
Now, over in sentry, which is that turret
that follows our mouse, you can say, if there's
a game.mouse, if we have some sort of movement,
I can go ahead and use the games mouse y and
mouse x and calculate accordingly.
Now, we want the game loop to be refreshed
every time. So at the end of the game loop,
we need to clear out, for instance, the clicks.
So, if I didn't click, the game doesn't remember
I had a click. So just always reset the state
at the end of that game loop. Now we should
have a turret and a grade. It's following
my mouse around. So now we have mouse movement.
And now that we added mouse click handling,
we can now start shooting lasers. So we want
to start handling the click. Shoot some lasers.
Now that we have aliens flying around everywhere,
and we have all these laser bullets flying
around everywhere. We need to start thinking
about do I need to manage these things when
they fall off the screen. So we're going to
introduce the concept of remove from world
bit, which is a simple bit here and the game
engine can check. And if it's true, it knows
to remove it at a managed entry. So over in
sentry, remember, in the update loop is where
you actually handle the click and do the work.
So we say if there is a game dot click, then
call shoot. And over in shoot we create a
bullet and give it to the game engine so he
can start becoming managed and update and
drawn. Over in bullet, we detect if we come
off the screen. And, if so, we set to world
equals true. In game engine we can loop again
and say did anything get flagged for removal
after our main update loop? This, obviously,isn't
super optimized code or anything. But for
the purposes of our simple game here, this
works great.
So we should have -- you should reload. Uh-oh.
There we go. If it doesn't come up, we'll
keep going. Okay. We'll come back to that
one. See if it pops in. Pretending we had
cool firing lasers there.
We want to make those hypothetical lasers
explode. So, to do that, we're going to add
to the concept of an animation class. Animation
class will handle something called a sprite
sheet. A sprite sheet is a collection of animation
frames all stitched together so that the animation
class can work through it step-by-step and
draw it quickly, makes it look like an animation.
Nice thing, by stitching everything together
to create one asset versus 10, 20, or 30,
there's a lot less resources going over the
wire. This is a good thing for performance.
And this is a concept familiar to game developers.
So sprite sheets are very handy. Turns out
that canvases draw image takes advantage of
this quite nicely. Because one of the overloaded
calls here can take a certain subsection of
your image, that is, your sprite sheet, pick
that up, and then draw it on the canvas to
your main game canvas. So it can work itself
through quite nicely. This is an example of
what an animation class would look like in
draw frame. He knows the time through the
game. This is another reason why the game
timer is so important. And then we call canvases
draw image, which knows what current frame
we're on. So we can calculate exactly how
far into the spreadsheet we need to go, pick
up just that subsection or subregion and then
draw it on remaining canvas. Animation class
would also know what current frame and are
we done with the animation or not?
So over in bullet explosion now, his draw
method -- we just simply delegate to his animation
class where we draw a frame inside draw. Now
you're asking where did bullet explosion come
from? Great technique here in game development
is you can actually change or swap entities
in and out. So instead of in the bullet class,
for instance, saying, if I'm exploding, do
this and, if not exploding, do that which
gets very complicated, a neat technique is
to remove one entity, swap in another entity
right on top of them. And the user never knows,
and it's just much simpler to manage different
entities. So here we add a bullet explosion
entity and then removed the bullet entity.
So now we're good. Now we have shooting. We
have bullets flying through space. We have
explosions. You can see the animation class,
work through the frames.
And I also use canvas as a scale method. So
as I move through the animation, I also scale
it up and up and up. So this is pretty cool,
but I think we can do better. We want sounds.
Those cool explosions. So HTML5 audio not
quite there yet for game development. There's
a lot written on this subject. I'd ask you
to go definitely research this yourself. I
think the good news here is the message has
been heard. So there's patches floating for
Chrome that should fix some of the major issues.
The W3C, for instance, is starting a group
called audio working group to look at what
a more robust audio API would look like. But
back in real life, we need to get this working,
we need to use sound manager 2. Sound manager
2 is a really neat simple API for playing
sounds. It will delegate to flash and also
delegate to HTML5 audio. So you can use code
today that is future-proof.
We're going to integrate sound manager into
our asset manager. Pretty straightforward.
One of the tricks here is you're going to
want to set auto load to true so that you
can preload all of your images and predownload
all of your sounds. So asset manager knows
how to kick off your game when all resources
are done downloading. And it's very simple.
You can ask the asset manager get the sound
and call play. And at this point, we're in
the sound manager 2 world. And he'll go ahead
and play. So let's see what it sounds like
here. All right. Now we're cruising. Pretty
satisfying explosions. That's pretty good.
Good base.
Now we're all set up to actually blow up the
aliens. So we need to add a collision detection
algorithm here. For a simple game we're going
to add a circle intersection algorithm. We're
going to give every object a radius. From
that radius we can determine if the two circles
that represent the objects collide. This,
obviously, doesn't work in all cases. But,
for this simple game, it will work great.
So, to do this inside bullet explosion in
his update method, we're going to loop again
through all the aliens on the screen and say,
"Hey, are you caught in my explosion? Are
you caught in my explosion?" And, if so, we're
going to implement our score and then trigger
the explosion game logic. So this works for
our simple game here, because there's not
that many entities on the system. However,
one of the early optimizations you'll probably
do is end up implementing something like spatial
partitioning which cuts up game board or canvas
into subregions. And you track which entity
is in which subregion. And then, when you
go to do a collision detection, you have a
much more narrow view coordinate into your
world and you'll have to check every entity.
So one Protip that I often like to do is for
all the entities in my game, when I do this,
I can do visual debugging and draw a circle
around my entity that just aids me in understanding
where I'm drawing things and visually debug
if the collision detection works. So, for
instance, it shows you how easy it is to draw
a circle around something. And, if I set this
one bit show outlines, all my entities will
be outlined. So now you can see the circles
are on the screen. Hopefully, maybe not. But
we should be able to fire away. [Audio sound
effects]
So now we have collision detection, extra
sounds for the alien explosion. And all right.
Great.
So now that we actually are able to blow up
some aliens, we're tracking some score, we
want to see what's my score? How am I doing?
So, for purposes of our simple game here,
we're going to use canvas's fill text. It
will draw text straight on to the canvas.
Very straightforward. Very simple. However,
you'll probably want to optimize this as well.
You can use a technique like sprite sheet
for game fonts. Impact has a cool tool for
this. And then using the same spreadsheet,
we can draw subregions on to your main canvas.
You can do the same thing with text sprite
sheets on font as well. You'll probably notice
the text in your game probably doesn't need
to be updated 60 times a second. The score
doesn't change 60 times a second. So in early
optimization, you'll probably want to employ
off-screen canvas approach for stuff that
doesn't change frequently like the game text
or the score. But, just to show you how simple
it is to do, we're going to ask the game to
draw score and draw the number of lives we
have left. And we're going to integrate that
in with the game loop. And then you can see
it's easy to draw text on the screen with
canvas. So we have 100% more scores. I left
this running. Shoot! I'm already super dead.
That's a simple way to get something like
text and score display onto the screen.
So, now that we've worked through a lot of
this and started thinking about performance,
you want to start asking yourself how do I
measure performance? There's two ways to think
about performance, especially in HTML5 games.
There's how fast am I drawing to the screen?
That's your draw loop. And how fast am I executing
the business logic or update loop? So you
can think of more complex games that might
have a physics engine. The optimizing how
you approach your physics loop might be different
than how you optimize and approach your draw
loop. So there's two different high-level
ways when I think about optimization. For
the draw loop we're going to -- there's a
great JavaScript utility calls stats.js for
Mr. Doobs. It draws a nice little canvas underneath
and gives you a rendering to visualize what's
happening. But That's his best approximation.
It turns out that Chrome in about flags has
a really cool way to display a true to life
FPS counter. And that's the best way to understand
how truly often is Chrome drawing to the screen.
To look at things like your physics performance
or your update loops, highly recommend developer
tools, the profiler that will go through and
tell you exactly which JavaScript calls you're
spending most of your time on.
And over in Mozilla, to get the best way to
look at how often I'm drawing to screen, they
have a cool mozPaintCount which you can query.
And that just increments every time you draw
to screen. And you can infer the FPS count
from that.
So a quick look at stats.js. This is what
it looks like. Draw a histogram of what your
FPS looks like from his best estimation. We're
actually going to add that into our game to
show you what's going on here. It's very simple.
You integrate that right into your update
loop. And then he will draw it for you. The
Chrome about flags here, FPS counter will
show in the upper left hand and give you a
true FPS. So the more you dive in, the more
you want hard core numbers. So I definitely
ask you to check this out. One note, though:
This will only turn on with hardware acceleration
for things like WebGL and soon-to-be hardware-accelerated
canvas. So you may or may not see this, depending
on your browser and game.
Here's what developer tools look like. I used
this, for instance, to determine how much
time I'm spending in actual draw alien call
for the optimization in image caching. This
is really, really great. I think you'll be
surprised about where you actually need to
optimize your code. You're probably thinking
I've got to optimize all these different for
loops everywhere. And you're probably going
to figure out where you have to draw less.
And this will confirm that for you. So 100%
more. How are we doing? Down here we have
19 frames per second. I think we can do better
than that. So I think that's due to the -- yeah,
being the iFrame. Here we go up to 44. All
right. We're doing okay.
Here come the aliens. Whee! So, anyway, a
good perspective into the performance of your
game.
And our final objective here is offline play.
A lot has been talked about offline for HTML5
tools and technologies. And I think I want
to point out that we're not necessarily interested
in true 100% offline like completely disconnected
all the time. Although that's a great goal.
And I think you can incrementally work your
way up there. But I think you want to look
at these technologies because you want transient
number activity. We're at the show. Wi-Fi
can be a little sketchy. It's important to
understand your user doesn't always have best
available network connectivity at 100% of
the time. Sometimes might even have no network.
So we want to compensate for that. And, of
course, you want to save bandwidth builds
for your service as well. So we're going to
employ application cache. Application cache
is a declarative way to signal all of the
static assets like JavaScript, CSS, images,
HTML, et cetera, and tell the browser to super
cache them. That is, cache them outside into
normal managed browser cache, more left indefinitely.
Normal application cache has a 5 meg limit.
But, if you install the game from Chrome web
store, you get unlimited storage.
So a couple tips here: The AppCache, the manifest
file has to change if you want anything to
be reflected on the client. So this is important
point. Always trips me up. I always forget
to twiddle. Just change the file in any way,
shape, or form to signal the browser to redownload
anything. Changes are reflected on the second
load. This is kind of a subtle point, in my
opinion. Might mess you up in your first set
of debugging. But the application cache, remember,
will download in a separate thread all the
assets. And then -- so, if your player is
playing and you've got a cache and everything
is working great offline and you've changed
something so that, while the player is playing,
it's redownloaded all of the assets. Again,
he's not going to see the new version. The
cache doesn't take effect immediately out
of nowhere. The user has to reload again.
So that the second time he plays again after
the update, he'll actually be pulling from
the updated cache. Something to keep in mind
and a little tricky. Highly recommend AppCache
info. Lot of great insider knowledge. Luckily,
a file is pretty straightforward. We just
declared all the different assets we're on
in no particular order. And this signals the
browser. All we need to do is declare this
as manifest attribute in our HTML file in
our document. And we have 100% more aliens
on the plane. I'm not messing with the Wi-Fi
gods. And you'll just have to take my words
for it here. But it totally does work.
So we actually ran through. And that was actually
pretty quick. All the different steps we need
from zero to hero to build a HTML5 game. Hopefully,
most of that was pretty straightforward stuff.
Luckily, we don't have to star from scratch.
There is a lot of interesting movement here
in the HTML5 game engine community. Couple
cool notes: Rocket engine, an HTML5 game engine,
bought by Disney no longer publicly available.
Aves, another HTML5 game engine, bought by
Zynga, no longer publicly available. Big companies
are investing in HTML5 games.
Stuff you guys can play with: Impact, they're
here at the show. Crafty is an open source
engine. Game closure, they're here at the
show. A couple others. I do want a special
call out to Forplay, which is an open source
GWT game engine. This is really cool. I highly
recommend you check out their talk tomorrow.
They're going to show something really, really
nice. Check it out. The many, many more links
here goes to a get hub Wiki page with a ton
of HTML5 game engines all in varying degrees
of completeness and features and whatnot.
So a lot of action going on here.
I know you're saying, well, mobile is hot,
hot, hot. How do I get in on that action?
Turns out game engines are thinking heavily
about this problem. So, for instance, Impact
recently released a cool blog post in addition
to their game engine that takes your HTML5
game written in JavaScript and uses canvas
and will get it at near native speeds on to
your IOS device. For instance, uses the nitro
JS engine to execute your JavaScript natively
and then will translate your canvas call to
open AL. So this is really, really cool. One
toolkit -- one technology toolkit like HTML5
multiple platforms does something very cool.
So does space board. Stick with HTML.
Another theme is you don't have to start from
scratch. A lot of us aren't artists. So I
do want to call out there are ways to get
assets you can use to start playing with HTML5
games. For instance, freecell.org has more
than enough to get started with. Free sound.
Any great development blog in general. But
they have cool artwork licensed for you to
use in your indie game. So we've built a really
cool game. It's all set to go. How do we get
it in the hands of users? Quick shout-out
to Chrome Web Store. This is the open marketplace
for web apps and web games. You can see here
numerous call-outs to games. Lord of Ultima,
Spark Chest and favorite games. Games are
really, really important to game store. There's
no up-front app review process. You can put
your game in. And it will be published into
the directory more or less immediately. Big
companies like EA, Zynga, Atari, Big Point
and Pop Cap and lots of other developers and
indies are putting their game into the store.
How to get started, call out to Appmator to
automate the process. This is a subtle point,
but something here to remember I think it's
key. Chrome Web Store users use Chrome. It
sounds totally obvious. If you think about
it, it means Chrome Web Store is your safety
net. You can build that awesome HTML5 game
and distribute it through an actual marketplace,
a store and be assured that your users are
using a modern browser that can run all this
awesome HTML5 awesomeness.
Success story here. World Golf Tour here,
for instance. So that's a lot of material.
This is just one talk? No. There's a lot of
stuff out there. For instance, there's a whole
other HTML5 game conference. There's a whole
bunch of people on Twitter who publish books
and write about this. And they actually make
games. Lots of different blogs. For instance,
Hive and go forward and publish their experiences.
And they build out their latest HTML5 games.
Function Source, the new web magazine online,
has a great article called HTML meet the world
of games. And I think probably most telling
here is game developer magazine, the magazine
has a feature article in HTML5 game development
this month. So to sum it all up, just remember
simple HTML5 games are just canvas and JavaScript.
And all the tools are already there in your
browser. No otherwise magic that you need
to get going. But let these game engines do
the heavy lifting. We looked at all the code,
and it might be interesting to build it up
from scratch and get a feel for what's going
on. Don't start from scratch. See one of these
game engines might help you get bootstrapped.
Remember then even Id, guys who make Wolfenstein,
even Rage coming out this summer, he said
if uncompressed Rage is going to be a terabyte.
So, even these guys, started with an 8 bit
scroller called commander king. So it's within
our reach to build great games and start with
a great experience. So definitely go out there
and have fun. I want to thank everyone for
joining me. We're going to do some live Q&A.
I encourage everybody to give me feedback
on the talk. I appreciate that. Everyone who
gets a live question gets a cool HTML5 keychain,
nice and heavy and hefty. You can see these
slides as well. We'll jump over to moderator.
And please do come up to the mics.
So thank you very much.
[Applause]
>>Seth Ladd: All right. You're fast.
>>> Number one.
>>Seth Ladd: Okay.
>>> So you were repainting the entire canvas
every frame, just clearing it out and restarting
it.
>>Seth Ladd: Yeah.
>>> So how important in game performance is
like using double buffering techniques or
doing incremental drawing and erasing and
moving things so like --
>>Seth Ladd: So -- yeah. That's a great question.
So generally you want to reduce the numbers
of drawing as much as possible, especially
with un-accelerated canvas, and so each technique
depends on your particular game, but we've
seen some really good performance improvements
by using, for instance, multi-canvas, just
laying them all on top of each other.
So, for instance, the background may not change,
so just draw that once, put another canvas
on top. That may be like one parallax which
moves slower. So that's a technique I've seen
work really well, but --
>>> So you have like transparent backgrounds
for the foreground canvases and then they
show through or --
>>Seth Ladd: Well, the canvas -- yeah. Because
if you don't draw on the canvas, you can set
it just with CSS to be transparent.
>>> Okay. Great.
>>Seth Ladd: So that's one way to handle it.
So let's take one from the Moderator here.
"Hi. Is there any statistical data about the
use of browsers today that can help us take,"
ta-da, ta-da, ta-da.
So basically can I actually do this in the
real world?
So the answer is: There's lots of data out
there, like ComScore and NetScore, Cass. I
mean, you can go find out for yourselves,
but the important thing to remember here is
that it's very relative to your audience.
For instance, the audience for TechCrunch
is going to be using a different browser than
the Wall Street Journal, for instance. So
it's important to always look at who are you
trying to hit and what browser they're running.
So, I mean, I don't have any stats on me,
but this is a good question, but I would say
especially with something like the Chrome
Web Store, you can publish right there and
just know, oh, everyone's on Chrome so -- question?
>>> Yeah. I'm wondering about 3D game play,
3D objects, robotic type things.
>>Seth Ladd: Uh-huh.
>>> Is HTML5 going to be able to support that
kind --
>>Seth Ladd: Sure. Yeah. So part of the Open
Web Platform, part of the family of HTML5
technology, is something called WebGL. WebGL
embeds a full featuring OpenGL ES 2.0 engine
right in your browser and that's how you get
the hardware side or GPU'd awesome OpenGL
graphics. Yeah.
So we'll take another one here.
"Are HTML5 games just another way to create
pastime games or is it kind of a real game
creation?"
Ah! I've heard this question a lot.
So the way I like to picture it is lots of
games are real, right?
So I -- for instance, we bundle Entanglement,
which is a really cool HTML5 game, very professionally
produced, very soothing soundtrack, and that's
a real game. That's all HTML5.
So I think what this is probably saying is
can we make triple A titles maybe on the order
of like Medal of Honor or Call of Duty. That's
probably a little bit a ways away. There is
a technology called native client which lets
you run C and C++ code natively and securely
on the browser. That's probably more in tune
with what this person is asking about.
Especially because AAA title game development
have a lot of investment in C code so that's
probably one thing to look at. Question.
>>> Hi. Can I ask two questions?
>>Seth Ladd: Sure. But you only get one key
chain.
>>> Okay. I'd like to ask: Is there implementation
for streaming audio and video or does it have
to be downloaded and cached?
>>Seth Ladd: That's actually a funny point
because the HTML5 audio tag as originally
envisioned was really a streaming audio -- like
that's what they originally kind of -- like
you can start playing like a song and it will
just play, and what they didn't really work
out is what games need, like fast iteration,
over and over and over play like for shooting
sounds and stuff.
So, yeah, HTML5 will have audio and video.
You can stream it.
>>> So like a 4 mega- -- you won't have to
wait for a 4-megabyte audio file to download
or anything like that?
>>Seth Ladd: If you want to play like a background
sound?
>>> Yeah.
>>Seth Ladd: Sure. In fact, that's actually
where HTML5 audio tag does a pretty good job
at.
>>> Okay. Then my other question would be:
The tutorial like you had right now, would
you be able to have that available publicly
so that maybe your average teenager can start
making his own games?
>>Seth Ladd: Absolutely.
So you can get the slides here. And then there's
a link to the game way at the front, and everything
is on Get Hub, so you can just pull it down
and play with it. But also Crafty is open
source as well so you can look at how they
do it.
>>> Okay. Thank you.
>>Seth Ladd: Uh-huh. Let's see here.
"Are there any plans to make web apps ask
for elevated privileges like full screen"
-- I think this is something we've been thinking
a lot about. We don't have anything to talk
about today. But, yeah, I think games do ask
for more elevated behavior into the system,
where you can do things like mouse captures.
I think we're well aware of that.
>>> What are some considerations for producing
games that are part of like a business type
of thing? There's some games that, you know,
actually are like sales for a business or
actually integrate with -- for instance, the
-- the golf one integrated with a lot of different
partners and things. What are some considerations
and how would HTML5 maybe be a special place
to do that?
>>Seth Ladd: So I think -- yeah, I'm not sure
I understand exactly the question. That's
a lot of business deals like you have to work
out with different partners.
As far as HTML5, I mean, there is -- you get
enhanced game play out of it because things
like the browser can now accelerate canvas
for you, or WebGL, and it requires less plug-ins.
It could be a good thing.
So maybe the sell of "I'm going to build my
game in HTML5 and future-proof myself as HTML5
gets on more and more platforms and devices."
That's -- that probably is the right way to
go. But yeah.
>>> Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
>>Seth Ladd: Sure. Chris?
>>> Two things. Keyboard accessibility was
a big problem when canvas came out.
>>Seth Ladd: Yeah.
>>> Is the impact engine or other game engines,
did they fix that?
And how do you stop people from hacking your
game and changing the scores in the JavaScript
itself?
>>Seth Ladd: Sure. Yeah.
So the first question, I don't -- I can't
speak for them. I don't know really what they're
doing and I'm not fully up on what the standards
bodies are doing with accessibility related
directly to canvas. That's a good question.
But impact is here at the show. We can chat
with them.
>>> No. Just keyboard controls. They were
always a problem to have keyboard-enabled
games.
>>Seth Ladd: Oh, oh, okay. So I -- so I've
written games with impact that handle the
keyboard just fine, so yeah.
>>> Okay.
>>Seth Ladd: The second question was how do
I stop people from hacking my game score?
Yeah, that's -- that's a tough one.
So in the end of the day, you probably want
to keep honest people honest, so tools like
GUID or Closure or any number of (inaudible)
obfuscation libraries for JavaScript will
obfuscate all the code for you, make it a
little bit harder. But really with like Firebug
and Developer Tools, you're going to be able
to go in and if you don't do a good job obfuscating
your, like, local storage calls, for instance,
you can't stop the hacker on the local side.
So I take that if I take that question and
go another step further, I think this really
speaks to something like server replay of
the game so you can move your -- and this
is where something like Node can really work
out, because if you write all your game in
JavaScript and then you move that same logic
over into a server, replay all the moves,
you can verify what they did.
And then for the monetization, for instance,
that's where in-app payment is really kind
of powerful because they're buying all these
virtual goods.
You almost just want your game to get out
to as many people as possible and then you
start buying these items, so... yeah. Good
question.
Let's see if we can take -- are there any
other plans to support sequence like the -- ah,
okay. Are there -- okay.
You would have to check in with the W3C audio
group for this. I don't know what their plans
are. I think they're more or less agnostic
to the encoding format. They're just trying
to get the audio to play, you know, frequently
and reliably, so I -- I don't know if there's
any other plans to introduce these other formats.
Question.
>>> Does the current Chrome browser on the
Android platform support the hardware acceleration?
>>Seth Ladd: That's a good question. So just
a correction there. The browser on Android
is not Chrome. It's just a Webkit based browser.
>>> Okay.
>>Seth Ladd: And I don't know, unfortunately,
what Android's plans are for canvas acceleration.
>>> Are they currently supported?
>>Seth Ladd: I don't know. Sorry.
>>> Okay.
>>Seth Ladd: Although you might want to chat
with Impact here at the show, for instance,
or Game Closure here at the show because they've
figured out a way to get all that running
natively. Yeah. That's kind of cool.
"How about using CoffeeScript" -- yeah. How
about it. That's pretty cool.
Question in the back.
>>> Yeah. I'm Indy Game Developer. You might
have seen me on Congregate and New Grounds.
So I have a big library of flex. I have a
big library of Silverlight. I'm not too proud
of that. Sorry.
>>Seth Ladd: Uh-huh.
>>> But anyway, so if I want to make a game
with HTML5 but I've already written half of
it in flex, what's my best plan as far as
migrating it?
>>Seth Ladd: Yeah. I'm not aware of anyone
that will take you from Action Script 3, which
is I'm assuming what you built it in, back
over to JavaScript, but I know that Untyped
Action Script is pretty close to JavaScript,
so I don't know of any -- any tools there,
unfortunately.
I will say, though, that, you know, with something
from the Chrome Web Store, I think it's very
pragmatic, right? Like you can put Flash games
in the Chrome Web Store and, yes, this was
a talk about HTML5, I definitely think it's
the future, but at the same time a lot of
people have Action Script skills and have
written out games. And so I think stepping
maybe one step back, as long as it's a great
game with great performance and plays well
in the browser, I think that's what users
really care about.
So --
>>> My users apparently all run Linux.
>>Seth Ladd: Aha. Okay. Well, sorry. You know,
I like Linux.
I think we're running out of the good questions.
Let me see. "Any" --
[Laughter]
"Will Google ever make a game." I don't know.
"Any future plans to include a game plan controller?
Supports?"
Yeah. I don't think there's anything concrete
here, but I think looking at the device API
and re-approaching that as far as accessing
the microphone and the -- and the camera,
I think the logical next step here is game
controllers as well.
So I think that it's something on our minds
but I don't think there's anything concrete
there.
I sort of answered that with Christian.
And browsers and versions. I tested this on
FireFox 4 and Chrome 11, so...
Okay. If there's no other questions, I think
we're all set, and again, thank you very much
for your time.
[Applause]